live [ __ ] life bro  dude i see so much like and i don't know  it might just be my like surroundings  but i see so much negativity and i just  like my goal in life honestly is to  bring as much positivity as i can to  everyone around me so just put out the  content do that daily how can i like do  that like do what i do like crazy just  post [ __ ] positive perspective no no  you're right what do you mean how can  you  nobody followed me either bro everybody  starts with zero followers what do you  mean how can you take your [ __ ] phone  turn the [ __ ] camera around hit  record and say some positive [ __ ] and  post it um let me just do it right now  right now  live [ __ ] life bro  i love you so much  [Applause]